oh my god oh my goodness
good right night night
here it goes
[Music]
my name is jonathan l farrow 2020 cepeda
and as a professional boxer
i'm 17 and 2 15 knockouts and today i'm
here to talk about
mike tyson and roy jones jr what's going
on it's your boy eddie truck gordon ufc
tough 19
champion overall record 15 and 6 for
some of the best guys in the planet
i'm super excited to talk about my role
model my dude mom guy
mike tyson vs roy jones but first
let's get into this jake paul nate
robinson fight
what a fight i already called it i said
that nate was gonna get
knocked out cold why because i've been
watching too many videos
nate is very very green to boxing he's a
great athlete
won the slam dunk contest being five
nine but
jake paul's been training every single
day
for a year he's been sparring real
fighters actual fighters and that was
the result he got knocked out cole but
good job and they showed a lot of heart
a lot of dudes don't step into the ring
it takes a different kind of animal to
subject yourself to that i ain't gonna
lie
i thought his athleticism would make the
fight go a little bit longer
i underestimated jake paul he showed a
lot of season in
every fight he's gotten better and
better and better and
nate was just rushing in and he
literally ran into the punt it was crazy
and i blame his coaches too especially
in between rounds
they gave him zero advice i honestly
don't even think he was sparring
i think he hired a fitness boxing coach
like we have all these days
he wasn't in the gritty boxing gym the
way jake paul was
but what i do love is that he had heart
because the referee kept showing him
after knockdown number two he was like
hey do you want to continue do you want
to continue
and he was battling with himself should
i keep going should i not
but he said yes i do so big ups big
props tony robinson
when it wasn't moving i was like holy
smokes i was a little concerned
i literally lost a friend last year who
passed away in a boxing ring
and it looked freaky just like that i'm
happy nate you know
was able to recover and it's okay but
he caught he go to battle i saw a whole
lot of memes
uh he could get a lot of endorsements
for a lot of mattress companies right
now
at the end of the day i'm praying for
his safety hopefully everything was all
right which
jake paul has absolutely lost his mind
he's calling out
conor mcgregor at this point fought to
be the greatest boxer of all time
floyd mayweather listen jake you're
doing your thing
you're getting better each and every
fight but stop trying to pick
the the highest cherries because it's
not happening i don't think jake will
last
three rounds of myself or jonathan let
alone conor mcgregor
so so cut it out then we have my two
favorite fighters of all time
mike tyson i'm the vicious most
brutalist champion
there's no one like me i'm gonna stomp
on your testicles i want to eat your kid
the baddest man on the planet youngest
heavyweight champion
then we have roy jones jr of four
weight class world champion and
heavyweight being one of them
and i'm so surprised he didn't come in
the right way yeah i must have forgot
i had goosebumps like my kids couldn't
understand
like we were watching two of the baddest
men on the planet
in their prime it was totally amazing to
see them
roy implemented his plan it was a little
lackluster
of coming in and holding him which we
gave him all the credit in the world
because
who wants to get hit by the baddest man
on the planet
mike tyson and what they say like when
george foreman
fought michael moore they always say
your power is the last thing to go
your speed reduces so mike still had
that power
i just feel roy was like you know what
i'm gonna be smart ain't nobody gonna
hit me
yeah i must have forgot get over here he
implemented his game plan
and i wish the rounds were a little bit
longer because i feel like the filling
out process
by the time they start to feel each
other out the round was over
i actually feel like tyson won the fight
and did you know enough to do it
to get the w they gave it officially a
draw tyson saturday you're gonna see
you're gonna see him fight again i
really really wanted the old types of
that
he's like i haven't slept with my wife
in a year
because i don't care if i live or die
that's the tyson i wanted to see i
wanted to see him to be ferocious we saw
flashes in round i believe seven
and then round eight towards the end you
saw flashes agreed you saw roy with the
little rope-a-dope with the little
walk-off
no look jabs that was pretty dope this
legends boxing is gonna go on
you already seen holyfield training he
looks like he's in six shape
i guarantee you're going to see
holyfield you're going to see shannon
briggs
you're going to see all these legends
come and actually have a platform
to make some money and also you know
raise some money for charity i
guarantee you you're going to see a
tyson holyfield fight i
like it it has to happen at this point
last night was amazing for jones last
night was amazing in general for the
entertainment world
and jay paul here you go on 17-2 with 15
knockouts
how good would that look on your record
that you knocked me out
and then you like okay i knocked out
this established fighter
let's go conor mcgregor let's go anybody
else like i said i think you're right ed
we're gonna see tyson and holyfield
fingers crossed for that
[Music]
[Music]
you